und zwar gibt es wieder eine neue aktion
diesmal kommt sie aus hessen und zwar
sich volker bouffier dazu entschieden
dass er auch zwei die 2g regel auf den
einzelhandel ausweite das bedeutet und
das ist kein scherz ist kein fake news
im supermarkt kann jetzt auch zweig
verhängt werden
das ist für mich wirklich ist so
unfassbar dass ich kaum weiß wie wir
gleich darüber diskutieren wollen denn
das bedeutet ganz klar dass menschen die
sich dagegen entschieden haben sich
impfen zu lassen wenn die supermärkte es
umsetzen sollten die zweijährige die
jetzt ja in hessen erlaubt ist denn
dürften menschen die keine impfung haben
nicht in den supermarkt gehen würde es
dann bald annonce in der zeitung geben
ich biete 12 euro die stunde für die
impfen der für mich in den supermarkt
geht es nimmt alles langsam eine form an
die wahnsinnig ist und ich bin dafür
dass die impfpflicht durch die hintertür
die wir längst haben in deutschland
endlich fällt